Бажаним гостем ви себе тут не відчуваєте. Судячи з того, як з тобою розмовляють.
Багато мігрантів у Німеччині почуваються, як Яйран.
Початок життя на новій батьківщині ускладнює скажена бюрократія.
Довге очікування на прийом у чиновників, складні курси німецької мови, постійні невдачі…
І все ж багато хто, як Каталіна з Колумбії, наважуються зробити цей крок у невідомість.
Хочу набути досвіду життя за межами своєї країни,
далеко від сім'ї, щоб зрозуміти, чи зможу з цим впоратися.
З якими викликами стикаються мігранти?
І як реагують німецькі установи на критику?
Дуже добре, дуже добре.
Каталіна Фахардо хоче поїхати до Німеччини - як педагогиня.
Для отримання робочої візи колумбійці необхідно володіти німецькою на рівні B2.
Тобто достатньому для спілкування та читання.
Але легкою німецьку мову не назвеш.
Вивчати німецьку мову як іноземну складно,
бо в ній багато дуже чітко визначених структур.
І ці граматичні правила швидко забуваються.
Інтенсивний мовний курс у Боготі починається з нуля і триває сім місяців.
Його організувало німецьке агентство з працевлаштування.
Студенти зобов'язуються займатися по кілька годин на день,
відмовляючись на цей час від іншої оплачуваної роботи.
Натомість вони отримують стипендію у розмірі близько 300 євро.
Каталіна вивчала в Колумбії педагогіку та психологію.
Тепер вона може працювати у Німеччині вихователькою в дитячому садку.
Втім, Каталіна не хоче зупинятися на досягнутому.
У мене склалося враження, що Німеччина є досить багатонаціональною країною.
Це гарне місце для того, щоб обмінюватися ідеями і займатися тим, що важливо для мене.
Це хороший спосіб розвиватися в моїй професії.
Через кілька тижнів у Каталіни іспит на рівень B2.
Якщо вона його не пройде одразу, курс буде подовжено, але розмір стипендії зменшиться.
Скласти іспит з першого разу вдається далеко не всім.
Звісно, ми сподіваємося, що всі здадуть успішно, але зрозуміло: здати B2 дуже складно.
Каталіні дозволять поїхати до Німеччини лише після того, як вона успішно здасть мовний тест.
Інакше візу вона не отримає. Досить стресова ситуація для молодої жінки.
Яйран Монтехо з Куби живе в Німеччині вже близько восьми років, наразі в Берліні.
І все ще чекає на дозвіл на постійне проживання.
Ось саме такий у мене вираз обличчя щороку,
коли я маю продовжувати свою візу, коли я у відомстві у справах іноземців.
Не знаю, що на мене там чекає цього разу, чи отримаю я черговий дозвіл на рік чи на пів року,
чи взагалі жодного. Це те, що я хотів тут висловити.
Яйран приїхав до Німеччини, оскільки на Кубі закохався у стюардесу.
Вони одружилися та вирішили разом жити в Німеччині.
Але попри шлюб із німкенею отримати візу виявилося непросто.
Щоб приїхати до Німеччини, ми мали довести - я і моя тодішня дружина -
що ми були разом, як довго, надати фотографії.
Ми надрукували такі фотографії.
Якщо немає переконливих доказів, то вас можуть взагалі не впустити сюди, навіть якщо ви одружені.
У Німеччині кохання в якийсь момент минуло.
Залишатися разом лише заради документів вони не захотіли.
І вже протягом трьох років Яйран змушений подовжувати свій дозвіл на проживання щороку.
Для цього потрібно постійно приходити до відомства у справах іноземців.
А це жахливо, тому що багато часу, дуже багато часу займає навіть,
щоб просто записатися на прийом у цьому відомстві.
Під час пандемії коронавірусу одного разу йому довелося чекати так довго,
що термін дії його дозволу на той час офіційно закінчився.
Через це він навіть втратив роботу.
Іноді це означає залишатися місяць чи два без роботи - це надто довго.
Ви собі, напевно, навіть уявити таке не можете.
Я навіть втратив квартиру, бо якщо ти не працюєш, ти не можеш собі її дозволити.
Яйран втомився від цієї ситуації.
Щоразу походи до відомства у справах іноземців непередбачувані.
Стоїш нескінченно у черзі: то співробітників немає на місці, то немає потрібних документів.
У Німеччині все працює інакше.
Наразі Яйран намагається записатися на прийом в управлінні у справах іноземців у Берліні,
де він нарешті мав би отримати дозвіл на постійне проживання
після восьми років перебування у Німеччині.
Але чи вдасться йому це?
І ось, приблизно через місяць, Яйран готується до зустрічі з чиновниками.
Звісно, я хвилююся. Але оскільки я отримав підтвердження
з відомства у справах іноземців, все в принципі має бути гаразд і не повинно зайняти багато часу.
До відомства у справах іноземців лише кілька хвилин їзди.
Після прибуття Яйран має спершу зареєструватися на пропускному пункті.
Перед будинком відомства в Берліні - багато співробітників охорони і людей,
які чекають на прийом.
Розмова зі співробітницею на вході триває підозріло довго.
Я мушу о 12:45 знову сюди прийти, оскільки мені перепризначили час прийому.
Репортерка: Вони сказали, чому?
Вони сказали, що просто змінили час і що мені слід радіти, бо я маю тепер трохи часу.
Яйрану доводиться чекати ще кілька годин - і сподіватися на те, що прийом таки відбудеться.
Адже йдеться про постійне проживання в Німеччині.
Дуже багато мігрантів скаржаться на подібні труднощі із записом на прийом в німецьких установах.
Чому це, власне, так?
Представники відомства у Берліні не схотіли говорити на камеру.
Водночас у такому ж відомстві в місті Ремшайд у землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія погодилися на зйомку.
Тут працюють 38 людей.
За вісім років персонал установи збільшився більш ніж удвічі.
Керівник відділу Дітмар Мурах каже, що з 2015 року кількість запитів на прийом різко зросла.
Це була, звичайно, велика хвиля біженців у 2015 році, яку всі пам'ятають і досі,
коли до Німеччини приїхало стільки людей.
Так було і в Ремшайді.
Якщо у 2013-14-му роках у нас у Ремшайді було приблизно 17 тисяч іноземців,
то тепер їх майже 24 тисячі.
Для багатьох служб у справах іноземців серйозним тягарем є не тільки стрімке зростання кількості мігрантів та біженців,
а й нестача персоналу. Відіграє роль і плинність кадрів -
у Ремшайді штат співробітників постійно змінюється,
оскільки деякі з них не справляються з навантаженням.
Після стажування мені спочатку довелося збагнути, що мій стіл ніколи не буде порожнім.
Тому що, на мій погляд, досягти цього практично неможливо.
Та й самі собою рішення, які доводиться приймати, пов'язані з великим стресом.
І вони не завжди даються легко.
Діалог з людьми, коли доводиться говорити їм:
вибачте, я не можу продовжити ваше перебування,
ми змушені попросити вас залишити країну.
Не тільки емоційний стрес - погіршує ситуацію також відставання в дигіталізації.
Тут у нас усе заповнено майже під зав'язку.
Але в іншому офісі, де я сиджу, шафи іноді настільки забиті,
що нам доводиться класти нові папки просто зверху або збоку, бо тут вони вже не вміщаються.
Недостатня цифровізація відчувається у Німеччині й в інших сферах.
Це проблема, на яку вже давно мають звернути увагу політики, вважають у місцевих органах влади.
Перенесемося назад у Боготу.
Каталіна з другої спроби склала мовний тест, необхідний для отримання робочої візи.
На роботу до ФРН її запросило агентство з працевлаштування Talent Orange.
І ось Каталіна з нетерпінням чекає приїзду до Німеччини.
Хочу набути досвіду життя за межами своєї країни, далеко від сім'ї,
щоб зрозуміти, чи зможу я з цим впоратися,
чи зможу я взагалі так жити - і тоді, можливо, залишуся.
Перед виїздом Каталіна проводить час із старшим братом Оскаром.
Вона молодша з трьох дітей у сім'ї та перша, хто наважився емігрувати.
Старший брат обіцяє незабаром відвідати її.
Нехай насолоджується і більше подорожує.
Ми знову в Німеччині, у місті Ганау.
Каталіна працюватиме в дитячому садку на кшталт цього.
У Німеччині не вистачає майже 100 тисяч вихователів у дитячих садках -
в одному лише Ганау дефіцит персоналу в дитсадках становить близько 80 осіб.
За рахунок залучення кваліфікованих іноземців місто зможе закрити
принаймні частину вакансій - і досі такий досвід був позитивним.
Ми бачимо, що "поїхати за кордон і працювати там" - дуже сильний мотивуючий фактор.
Даніела Нойа з Колумбії до Ганау переїхала вже близько року тому. Як їй тут живеться?
Одна складність - це погода, оскільки у нас у Колумбії немає пір року,
і зима була дуже складна для нас. Ну, і, мабуть, мова.
Стикаючись з бюрократією мігранти, які приїхали до Німеччини через агентство з працевлаштування,
мають явні переваги. Інша ситуація, якщо людина приїхала самостійно - як, приміром, Яйран.
В очікуванні відкладеної зустрічі він провів кілька годин -
і тепер знову йде до установи, щоб нарешті отримати дозвіл на постійне проживання.
Я хвилююся і тим не менш сповнений надії, що цього разу все вдасться.
І знову натовп іноземців перед відомством,
і знову Яйран повинен проходити повз охоронців.
Цього разу кубинця впускають всередину.
За кілька хвилин він повертається.
Так, вийшло. Тривало трохи довше, зате вийшло, і картка ПМЖ у мене!
Оце моя стара, а це нова.
Яйран Монтехо таки досяг свого після восьми років перебування в Німеччині
та незліченних зустрічей з чиновниками.
Це справжній прогрес. Мені не треба більше сюди приходити.
Життя продовжується.
Наступний можливий крок для Яйрана - німецьке громадянство.
Шлях до нього також, швидше за все, буде пов'язаний
із численними перепонами та неприємними сюрпризами.